quite simply put he was on one of the
most popular television shows of all
time
and CSI Miami and right now his careers
all about if you will
spin-offs better call Saul season 5 on
AMC the sequel of Breaking Bad he's
currently in season 3 of young Sheldon
which is the spin-off prequel to the Big
Bang Theory and he will be reprising his
role on sergeant frank trip on re s
Miami which I'm a huge fan of yours but
right back at you right here's the thing
I have grown to be a big fan of these
two convicts over here it's not a mr.
Mike Dell - phoner mr. Chris Braman both
have a long history of horribly bad
fantasy teams Oh until game Annex
spoiler alert
we will be delving into in our show
opens for Laurie as Miami as we will now
when the highly talented individuals
here at audience and DirecTV and Kelly
back Richard Charney and their group
came to they came to me Rex
they said we got two ideas for your show
open for Miami for the Super Bowl shows
I'm like okay what do you got they said
the first one is you play David Caruso
and we do a whole send up of CSI Miami
and I said I don't care what your second
idea is that's it love this over because
to get to be dress up like Caruso and
then to have you involved was a total
blast for me an absolute total blast
well you were I mean you brought a lot
of joy did you guys not love seeing him
left now love you but you are great
though cuz when we're shooting the whole
thing a couple times you're just like
now here's what you should do like maybe
a hunch your shoulders a little bit all
the sudden I was looks thinking wait a
minute he can't walk before me because I
the grunt detective has to go first and
Horatio has to make his cool
then I started getting into it I started
the show you turned out great for me too
I was having a blast yeah it's like old
times huh it was fantastic Slyke I win
yeah I've had a great time on that show
you know we were it changed everybody's
lives really we were we were the number
one wants show for five out of those ten
years and number one what's showing the
world and yeah so we got they treated
this great Miami and we were we were
kind of like rock stars in Miami it was
really fun
I say rock stars I was and I was like
you know there were a lot of
good-looking girls before me and then
and then Horatio really good looking
guys and then there was Frank threat so
Caruso the one thing the one note you
didn't need to give me because I I knew
this from back in the day when I from my
two episodes of CSI Miami Rex as you
know that I know you're a you're a
veteran of the show well you are my two
episodes of residuals I do and as a
matter of fact I'm gonna want you to
stay one extra segment so I can open up
my residual checks how great would it be
like open up my residual check from the
episode page or deep freeze those were
my two remember the old cage yeah rich
of course and that that I knew that he
always this was his move he would put
the glasses on to deliver the line you
not take them off to deliver know all we
all and with his hands like just
gingerly holding them right I'm he's
brilliant he was brilliant at that and
also even in our segment Ras CSM or
arias Miami yes when he left out of
frame he did it deliberately everybody
that tries to mimic David going out of
frame they do it in a hurry button no
baby he just did that he just Cris
Collinsworth late career slid out it was
funny of a good couple times I would
just put the glasses on and deliver the
line and you go you got to leave frame
rich well you did that you know you did
that when you presented me with the mm
by the way yes I was looking at my woody
yes
[Laughter]
my first time the first time I ever met
Rex Linn Wow was on the site skull
pelvis total access Oh God
and it was the celebrity fantasy
football league that Rex Linn won and
the trophy was called the woody guys
thank you for the concert said 2006 that
was 14 years ago where yeah can you
believe that and I'll never forget I
never played fantasy football before I
was nervous because it was Rich Eisen
but then we go to the day that were
filming the draft so I stopped at the
the magazine stand the advant is in
Ventura Boulevard and I got an NFL
fantasy league magazine yes I took it to
the draft I set between Paul Rudd on my
left Jeff Garlin all right they had
graphs and rulers and all this stuff and
they were looking and I'll never forget
Jeff Garlin looking over at me and he
goes and deadpan and he said is that all
you brought and I said yeah and he said
well good luck with that and then Paul
Rudd looks over and he reaches over and
he taps my magazine he goes and he goes
you're gonna go a long way with that my
team was t-rex and I beat their butt and
you want a television right we actually
get I was a huge 55 inch which was giant
then yeah till his TV screen and I got
my woody Jermaine question where do you
keep your woody my woody says
prominently on my office desk so every
walks in can see my woody
congratulations
man now did did you defend did you come
back the next year and defend well no no
I didn't owe you one and done I got well
I got busy and I couldn't do it and but
I saw Paul Rudd later he never forgot it
you remember his team was taste like she
says let's mine was t-rex and I saw him
on the red carpet at some premiere
several years after that he never forgot
he walked over he goes
t-rex man Rex Linn here on the rich eyes
of show I remember too when I did come
to the set of CSI Miami again to to
finish up what I started in caged with
deep freeze and I believe it went in
that in that order you were driving
around on the set in a golf cart with
Texas Longhorns like literal Longhorns
on the front like a custom-made well we
did that for you now I know you're a
Wolverine
I'm a born Texas Longhorn fan have been
all my life but I talked to the
Teamsters and I said look first of all
the fact that you were gonna come with a
crew to present that yes the whole crew
went crazy they were so excited that you
were gonna be there that's right I did
present the woody on the setting so we
presented instead of dinner in the
studio we rich presented me the woody on
the set and got to do his best David
Caruso which was great best ratio yes
anyway so I can went to the Teamsters
and I said guys if first your hisin is
gonna come to this set we got to make it
we got to make a big deal out of it and
so we need to get a golf cart we need to
get a football on it
we need against and I just said this is
a joke we need to get some Longhorns put
on the front of this card well the next
day they had huge Longhorns it was
amazing bolted on the golf never seen
anything like it it was fancy whistle
people definitely knew that they had to
get out of the way and I just also
remember being on the set Caruso was so
cool he had like a sense of humor about
things too he was great with it man he
well he was excited that you were coming
and they said you're the third floor the
producers we call the third floor up
there they they said they would love to
have Rich Eisen on the set presenting
the award but I needed to clear it with
David or supers I called David super day
so I called David and I said you know do
you have a problem with Rich coming and
giving me the woody first of all well
that's odd
he's gonna be wondering I said the
football it's called the woody and they
said he said I said but he's going he
wants to do it in a horatio thing with
it he goes best of luck to him I want to
be there and I said well you're gonna be
there because we're both working
together so anyway he loved it he raised
you though I think the thing that was
amazing Chris that there was I remember
this case of Maui Jim sunglasses like
pan of them 12 like and they were all
perfect pristine and I guess it was just
like choosing your your weapon you know
what I mean and putting them on I asked
my may I may I take one and go for it
and like Caruso picked it huh
hands it to me and I promptly lost those
sunglasses within two days because I
cannot keep anything fact they were but
I tell you I should never have one but
you guys if everyday don't you take Rich
Eisen for granted come to work cuz I
mean you should bow down because at the
time of 2006 when he presented me the
woody the thing is that we were the
number one watched show in the world and
the crew was more excited about Rich
Eisen coming to the set than anybody
that we had as guest stars they were
like flap do you know Rich Eisen I said
well yeah I mean through that throughout
the football season oh I got to know
Rishon they were super excited yet same
kind man and it was just again so great
to get you back in the role of frank
trip and our show opens are so silly and
fun and Colin Hanks is in it too and
Colin's gray it was just such a fun day
on the senton so many people just loved
hearing all your stories from your
career I'm wonder what stories you told
that day that you're able to tell on
live television and radio one
know that you didn't tell Tim cop what
was that like on the set of ten cop are
you right what was that like but that
was great Kevin Kevin and I called that
movie our field and stream movie because
we we were shooting six-day weeks but we
filmed half of it Tucson half of it in
Houston and but Kevin and I would either
hunt birds or golf
on Sundays right matter wherever we were
so we call it our fill and stream movie
but I do have a story you had told me
Chong on yes yes I did I was here at the
time of tin cup Cheech Marin became
obsessed with golfing I mean he he had
in the makeup trailer he had a video
where he'd plug in a VHS and he was
watching golf swings and it was it was
sick really it was sad not old but at
the end of the filming yes of timki we
had a cast vs. crew golf tournament okay
they picked the teams out of a hat
Cheech was my partner huh and she but as
I said she she had become obsessed with
learning golf the night before the
tournament Ron Shelton took a lot of us
out the cast out we went to an Italian
restaurant in Houston hmm and Cheech was
there early on and he said hey dude
here's the deal we got a 6:30 shotgun
start so we need to get to bed we need
to leave dinner early and I said for
what reason mm-hmm
he said I'm not I'm serious about this
we got to try to win this tournament I
said you're a 28 handicap it's a it's a
scramble Don Johnson's
a scratch golfer Kevin's six what he
footed what are you I mean we don't have
a chance and he said if we focus we
could do it all right fast forward about
6:20 a.m. we're in a golf car were on
the 13th hole so we're traveling to the
13th hole for a shotgun start yeah
Cheech pulls out what appeared to be
like the Star Trek Enterprise spaceship
with a lighter
I said you're not gonna smoke that this
early are you need he does this I'm like
a go he goes have you had your coffee
yet leave me alone man that started our
6:30 shotgun start baby it was a great
way to start for the first time your
filmography is something else man I mean
crush it rush hour
rush hour yeah one of my favorites what
was that I do you got a good story for
lunch oh god you can see actually I'll
tell you the watching Jackie Chan and
Chris Tucker together they had no idea
when they were maybe they did but when
they put those two together they had a
billion-dollar franchise sure coming to
fruition but I'll never forget we they
did the outtakes on the movie and Chris
Tucker man the first of all I have the
utmost respect for Jackie Chan I fell in
love with him the dudes he's a good
human being he took us all the dinner
all the time and everything but Chris
Tucker couldn't get Chelsea Clinton he
couldn't get it out and I only had that
day I only had one line and I was not
even talking to Chris's character okay I
had headphones on out and I was supposed
to turn I go they're gonna come down on
fourth streets or whatever the line one
mmm so he couldn't get Chelsea out and
it was Kelsey or or chalisa or what I
mean he came up and he they just kept
saying yeah we're still rolling Chris
it's Chelsea Clinton here's I know what
it is he goes well you're not saying it
so anyway about 13 takes later he says
it right I completely vapor lock I told
him I didn't know what my line was
I don't know Chris man we started
laughing so it was that every day on
that movie before I let you go better
call Saul comes back this is as good as
it gets Rex I know you've done a lot of
great stuff in your career and obviously
you're on young Sheldon right now but
this is to me the the haute cuisine of
of television and so the connect if
we're gonna see some connective tissue -
Breaking Bad this year I mean I don't I
don't want you to tell too many times I
can't really tell anything because I
don't know anything because they don't
let us know anything but I will say this
outside of what you shall say this
season five on better call Saul if you
were or are a Breaking Bad fan buckle up
buttercup because we're gonna ease into
some things that are that people are
going to love and the thing is Vince
Gilligan and Peter Google also said you
know they've asked all the audience to
be patient you know season season five
gets really it just gets it's they take
you into the fray and you get to see a
lot of Saul Goodman and a lot of things
start to happen and all of your patients
as an audience member will pay off is
everyone I love that it's going to be
rock and roll but I use the phrase it's
cooking well you know and I'm proud to
say that they put my character right
dead center in the middle of the fry so
much I'm very excited about that time
you play Kevin Wachtel of the Mesa Verde
Bank and Trust Bernie
oh yeah Mesa Verde what a great name for
a bank right Mesa Verde so good well as
I say happy banking also again catch him
on young Sheldon on CBS which is
Thursdays at 8:00 Eastern Time and then
of course front-and-center and re s
Miami every single day next week it's
gonna be fantastic baby here the man
wrecks it what's your Instagram by the
way you're on Instagram correct - you're
not I have some followers what is your
rucks lin 13 okay there you go
in 13 check him out when we come back
I'm an open residual checks and man if
they're not CSI checks I mean that will
be so disappointed is literally about
80% of the market oh that's next on the
Rich Eisen show
Rex Linn you are here hit the hit the
drop please let go for please
[Music]
that's me and he's Manny Rex using the
letter opener given to me for by my mom
and dad 2 4 6 what letter which envelope
- - envelope number - come on go
please be caged I'm excited you must get
CSI residual checks all the time right
right I do
all right everybody come on now come on
now
it is for I'm sorry
cursed me out here we go
Andrew savage thank you for residual
check of 38 dollars and 20 cents this
one more that's sort of we're gonna
finish up strong
oh no it's for late night Late Night
with Seth Meyers that's sick not a bad
check - good one it's 42 bucks Hey okay
well that's all right what's the first
residual check that you ever got my
first residual check was proud of it
money in Walker Texas right oh yeah
remember how much yeah it was $54 no
look God that Texas Ranger could walk
and it went from well it went from 50
Ford of like 10 and I just got one for
you no I'm gonna keep it tested I got it
was for $0.99 99 that's pretty cool yeah
put it next to the woody very few things
get next to the water just be surfing in
this conversation is the matter with
those two it's a trophy people for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel - 39 on
TV for free on BR live or download the
Rich Eisen show app